[Musik]
servus mit herzlich Willkommen zu
Fitness Tips mit kak stangel Ihren
persönlichen Personaltrainer wir haben
alle einen Körper und dieser Körper ist
wie wir alle wissen nur einmal jung und
wenn man diesen Körper so in Form halten
will wie ich dann muss man trainier
trainieren eisern trainieren teilweise
sogar mehrmals im Monat da muss man
laufen da muss man rumhupfen geh da muss
man uminander Kugeln oder auch mit
Gewichten teilweise sogar mit Geräte und
was es gibt aber was die wenigsten
Menschen wissen man muss auch eine
gewisse Geschmeidigkeit bewahren nicht
Dehnungsübungen muss man machen das
haben dieen Wikinger schon gewusst bevor
der Dorf überfen haben haben die immer
Dehnungsübungen gemacht da muss man die
Arme muss man dennen die muss man denen
und was ganz wichtig ist auch die
Bauchdecke muss gedehnt werden und W man
das macht ist zich da setzt man sie
einfach ganz locker und geschmeidig
setzt man sie her und dann wird die
Bauchdecke von innen her gedehnt das ist
das sogenannte
Stretching jetztt da so ein leichtes
ziehen ganz leichtes Ziehen von Ihnen
hier das kom man natürlich
steigern wunderbar jetzt merkt man wie
es da drin Arbeit wie sich alles dehnt
wie alles wunderbar ist das ist ein ein
herrliches Gefühl ist es und wenn man
das mehrmals macht dann merkt man schon
nach wenigen Tagen einen
Trainingseffekt ich sag wie es ist ich
glaub ich vertruck direkt nur eine
zweite Trainingseinheit BR B Schenk nur
[Applaus]
H